début de l'automne le parc floral se
réveille doucement sous une drôle de
brume
l'arrosage l'une des nombreuses tâches
quotidiennes réalisée par l'équipe du
parc aujourd'hui et jardiniers
travaillent sur les massifs avec la fin
de l'été il arrache un gros chantier
mais qu'on ne s'y trompe pas ces plantes
vivaces demande à l'année beaucoup de
travail de la taille du désherbage par
exemple c'est pour tous les jours ces
périodiques mais il faut four on y
revient en principe une fois par mois
quand on a fini un bout du massif
il faut presque recommence à black book
quoi c'est ça ces planches ne sont pas
jetés mais emmenés à l'abri des regards
pour être rempoter à la base des tiges
on va avoir des yeux qui vont redémarrer
et qui redonneront les nouvelles tiges
pour l'année prochaine donc là on a un
pied qui est relativement rose qu'on
peut faire c'est dans un deuxième temps
pour pouvoir le diviser de là naîtront
deux pieds ils grandiront au printemps
prochain
la base du métier de jardinier c'est
avant tout d'anticiper
c'est toujours une remise en question
parce qu'on travaille avec du vivant
on travaille avec des plantes donc une
année et pas l'autre une année un
développement va être différent que ce
soit voilà par rapport aux saisons par
rapport donc je dirais que c'est
toujours une éternelle remise en
question créée en 1963 le parc floral de
la source compte 35 hectares plantes
vivaces ou annuelles arbustes ou arbres
majestueux une quinzaine de jardiniers a
sur la vie de cette diversité
ils ne se servent pas toujours de leur
main pour arracher
mais reste attentif aux racines on met
tout en oeuvre pour pouvoir pour pouvoir
les préserver un maximum sur une attaque
le système racinaire évidemment ça à
cause des faibles et 50
mais bon il arrive des fois que ben on
ne peut pas faire autrement
certains sont statiques d'autres un peu
moins
forcément une surface totale de 10
hectares à tondre ça donne un peu la
bougeotte
normalement c'est un collègue toutes les
semaines on est à peu près 4 tondeur est
donc on fait un rouge ce soir votre
temps de chez vous vous en entendez pas
parler oui quand on fait ça toute la
journée on a fait une bonne journée
diversité des espèces et des métiers le
parc de la source
encore plein d'histoires à nous raconter